pourquoi raconter toujours des anecdotes
sur une sur nous est ce que vous ne leur
accorde une sur vous bonne idée je
trouve ça bien donc je suis en corse à
ajaccio et j'attendais un bateau comme
ça et je vois un énorme et yachts
magnifique et le gadget et pmp mathieu
gibaud votre bateau qu'est ce que tu
veux visiter jeu mongis dessus au port
je les ai tapé dix et 15 banques qui le
visitent hanoune a été là il ya quinze
jours il vaut mieux acheter
[Rires]
ajaccio tu vois le calme pas du tout
alors je me dis c'est n'importe quoi il
ya beaucoup de gens qui disent que je
vais acheter beaucoup de choses mais
trash est rien saisissez un saut ça mais
je pense qu'on est les bretons anecdotes
apps jurés ajouté au bas des fausses
tapas tapas d'éviter battant en corse
pas du tout jamais non pas ça ne rigole
pas tu mens je n'ai jamais été de battre
au corps
qui va me tomber
dans un avis de rabat hassan a dit
et
ce sera la fin du jour à bateaux ça
navigue à intervenir tout à l'heure
j'espère qu'il va le dire
voilà non mais vous avez d'autres
anecdotes allez-y c'est le jour où j'ai
une anecdote sur moi qu'ils avaient
entendu n'hésitez pas d'éclats
maintenant je vous dis si elle est vraie
ou alors oui c'est porsche une
oui j'ai déféré visiter une remise et
une voiture que j'avais à l'époque donc
d'accord voilà et on me dit qu'il peut
re bousso est là parce que c'était 911 à
l'époque comédie à monsieur hanouna qui
vient d'acheter une grise si bas donc
voila quoi c'est pour s'en passer
je sais pas qui est se soucie beaucoup
d'entre eux
récemment j'étais sûr théâtre fois on
m'a dit hanouna veut acheter la chair
[Rires]
c'est pas vrai mais ces
choses et donner grandes marques oui oui
mais j'étais au bourget à les arrêter
j'assure non on n'est plus votre
anecdote mais bien sûr oui mais je ne
mens jamais et on m'a dit ah c'est
rihanna qui vient de passer ils
descendent et son jet
set
arrêtez de dire des conneries non mais
son arrivée est ce que je vous ai déjà
menti oui ben alaoui bin non tu souffles
ou d'amis footballeurs oui parce qu'on
voudrait pas de sony dans le métro
et
et il ressent encore spatiaux bois de
boulogne
m
il voulait acheter un arbre
c'est fou c'est pousse à d'autres
anecdotes à l'édition je vais vous
attendez vous ce qui vous avez des
choses à dire de klimato castaldi
l'entrée du tout je suis passé j'ai bng
hier et tout allait bien beau
[Rires]
tout ce que vous avez dit
oui c'est vrai quoi vous c'est vrai bien
sûr et je vous jure que l'anecdote sur
le bateau est fausse d'ailleurs mes
visites bâton il ya deux ans vous êtes
pas visité deux bateaux tous annoncés
paille a donné bien qu'un jour
dieu sait réellement tu mens mais c'est
eto'o qui bouge la tête
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi
j'invente rien du tout je vous le dis je
vous dirai la vérité sais pas je suis un
fan de plaisance
patrick swayze n'a pas de blog et je
vous jure que c'est vrai à chaque fois
les mecs veulent me faire visiter leur
bateau c'est pas pour l'acheter ce n'est
pas ne sont pas des bateaux à vendre sur
des bateaux à visiter j'aime bien je
vais dans les salons je regardais bâton
comme des musées j'aime bien j'aime
rêver quand vous faites
vous lécher les vitrines pas moi je
laisse les bateaux là
bas c'est ça et bah oui
c'est vrai
une fois j'étais chez moi vous m'avez
pelé ou éditer ou chasse mais il est où
ton n'a pas donc je dis oui mais il est
comment je dis comment il est j'achète
ce soir arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais tout de suite très savent si
c'est vrai il me dit je te faire un
virement ce soir
non c'est bon c'est bon
ça va c'est bon là non mais cette
démission démarre très mal j'ai un ami
ce soir il incombe à côté de mon blouson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous dégoûter
je participerai pas à cette curée merci
ou alors on parle de dubaï non
ces voitures mal à cacher tout vous avez
vu qu'on peut retourner en amérique ça y
est
cbg était quasi seul avec vous en loge
c'est vrai que vous avez entendu parler
d'un appartement qui avait l'air assez
sympathique à dubaï et que vous avez dit
si baisse de 20% je l'achète demain
millions d'euros et selon mes
informations il a baissé de 20%
c'est faux je vous dis ça mais faut il a
le secret combien tu es font ça n'existe
pas je n'ai rien à dubaï gerin nulle pa
castanet non j'ai maintenant personnes
en amérique ça y est c'est libre oui
alors et bat donc c'est bien pour vos
maisons
et miami et new york et new york et los
angeles est
également non je ne
les écoute aussi
j'avais acheté à conques où nous n y
allez vous pourrez m'inviter mais j'ai
dit ça coule t il à 15 bagnole mais pour
faire bien que distille circulent de là
dans la rue il ya une petite clio
électrique
je rappelle que nous rencontrions qui
polluent et objets de se connaître
j'ai pas de yacht j'ai pas de jets et
trouvez moi des voitures jaunes alors
avec grand plaisir vas-y trouvez moi une
voiture ben oui là dans la plaisance
et la dia cloud by a que de la calomnie
comme design colas a réagi la calomnie
l'on reste toujours que coûte
nicolas pernikoff j'ai quelque chose à
dire alors moi je suis le restaurant
maintenant c'est vrai ça ouais et on m'a
dit tu sais que tu viens de deux piétons
édition à cyrine appartient sienne
mais il en reste aussi invités à jeter
quoi mais c'est pareil a dit
rester assez c'est celui qui est près de
l'ancien siège d'rtl là bas
oui
bien crevard parce qu'on n'est pas tous
au courant à n'avoir pas ça mérite un
petit café investigations tout ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si vous voulez parler parler ma fiancée
non écoutez on a fait les restaurants
mon vélo jet on a fait détruire tout est
faux tout et on a fait les dents si on y
va de votre parce qu'on a un petit prix
d'ami ah non j'ai payé
même moi je paye à voir ça pas parce que
oui parce que je veux pas faire des
trous dans la caisse forcément
vous n'aurez pas de café quand on y va
alors le café à envier aux dires de
patrick heuscher de plus en plus cher
n'importe quoi si george clooney nous
regardent mollo frères vont alors je te
le dis non non qu'est ce qu'il ya non
mais quand mélangent aux gardes alors je
le dire patrick est ce que c'est un ami
je le souhaite ou pas oui c'est faux
tout est faux dieux flavien c'était fou
tout et vous à côté lalanne défaut pour
info je t'aimerai toujours
des fous non mais alors bah ouais le
bateau j'ai pas vous avez pas lu la
trame n'est plus à lui inventer des
choses mais la voiture dis pas que ta
pas une voiture des classes j'ai tous
des cas ça hyper quitté gary thayer
sekkaki argent
quoi il ya d'autres personnes qui ont
des voitures de luxe ici oui castanet
avec la légende les gens ne s'est pas
arrêté de calomnier il faut qu'ils
sachent la vérité cyril assez il a une
seule chose il a ça dans sa vie ce
studio ils habitent là ça c'est ça c'est
ça change voilà son réveil qui le réveil
de 6 à 7 c'est plein il ya une salle de
bain de sang et le soin ridoret ici la
semaine
la pâte en balles
je cherchais je cherchais